in the lead this is a must-win situation
for
wei making a comeback in game three and
it is prague with the white pieces
what's going on and the game has just
started and we're going to see an
opening we very rarely see um oh what's
even the name of this is it the old
indian
i played this is the last game i played
in a competitive tournament i played
this as black okay uh and i did horribly
um it's the czech bononi i think isn't
it
yeah it used to be a bit of a joke um
with this opening in the english circuit
i mean i know um if something went wrong
like you know like if you had a bad
dinner or something if you go oh it's a
bit checked benoni or if you know or or
something didn't you know whatever if
something went wrong it was the czech
bononi that's what everyone thought
very bad reputation has
not been a very good opening for black
actually um and in order to win
it's a strange choice because you block
up the center of all your pawns there so
you don't have many pawn breaks and you
give space away so it's uh it's yeah i
wouldn't
expect this in a must win situation yeah
i guess wei yi his whole uh concept is
that he's keeping as many pawns as many
pieces on the board as possible he's
going to hope that prague who does have
a history a track record of getting low
on the clock he's going to hope that
prague's nerves come into play that uh
maybe those will be a factor time
trouble later on in the game here we see
black is the first to castle but white
doesn't necessarily even need to commit
his king because the center is so
blocked as simon mentioned there are
actually choices here white's king
sometimes goes the other way
or he delays that decision as long as
possible first the bishops come out
computers always love these positions
for white because white has more space
if you look at that central structure
it's like an arrowhead white's pawns uh
pointing in the middle of the board
black's pawns are kind of
yeah much more reactive
black later often tries to play on the
right half of the board i'm sure prague
will try and lock things down though as
much as possible he only needs a draw so
he's happy as long as the game is under
control you don't want to allow black to
break out that's what it's all about
right now yeah
but the breakout will happen um
eventually eventually so a plan that
i've
just put down my cup of hot water is
that uh you know you can do the what has
a name when you actually fianchetto
your side and then you re you put your
knight on that the g7 square so for
example you could start with uh
retreating the black knight and uh just
to show the route you put your knight on
this g7 square i'm not sure the name
either ivanka but has has a name i think
it does stupid
now the first you know the first time i
saw it done i was like oh my goodness me
what is this and then you know i think
it was a grand master did it i was like
never seen that before and then you know
when i kind of became a bit more
familiar with the ideas i was like oh
okay
it's an official thing i mean i know uh
aronian plays this way leveronians
sometimes the black black pieces but
there's not many grand masters uh in the
world who play the czech pinoni i mean
it's really rare uh but putting the
knight here is the only way you can try
to play f5 but i really i mean i i can't
maybe understand a little bit by why way
he's playing this way because he wants
to keep peace on the board he's going
he's going for the stupid night maneuver
um so i can understand what he does he
keeps all the pieces on the board he's
hoping he gets some chances later on but
that's your only break your only break
is to play that pawn you have no other
breaks and if white just puts all his
pieces to stop that break
i i you know i think it's very hard to
to break out and the way that prague's
played this he can he can play his pawn
uh to g4 at the right moment to to work
against that and it i it could be very
hard to break out in this position you
think he will get it you think he will
break out here i mean i i possibly i
mean one idea as well in the current
position i'm slightly surprised he
started with this pawn push because uh
you're normally you're supposed to start
with the knight because here white could
actually kick your rook to a bad square
the rook under attack and now white
could push the pawn even further and how
is this knight even getting i mean it's
a bad square g7 as we talked about but
how is this knight ever moving
i mean i'm surprised probably didn't
take this opportunity i thought this was
quite a well-known pattern and now the
black knight just can't even use this uh
use the circuit instead he's gone for
the same idea uh pushing forward this
pawn but at least the black knight if he
really wants can still reroute around
this way and he does that
but all white has to do here surely is
put the bishop just aim everything at
that pawn break literally put everything
to stop that pawn break and then just
wait yeah and there's nothing black can
do if you do this you've got two pawn
breaks you've got the one that we talked
about and you've got the other one on
the queen side but they're both covered
so well buy everything and you don't
have to do anything but maybe this is
where he's thinking oh prague's going to
do something because he's done something
in everything else's game but i mean you
can shoo it's really hard to break if if
you just play this way i just think this
is the perfect setup with all these
pieces um in a blocked position they are
poised they're ready to
uh
to mobilize later um if black does break
out at the wrong time this maneuver as
well i've seen this from as you
mentioned from level and aronian the
black knight coming to this square we're
gonna see something very weird
potentially for example if white just
waits uh i'm not sure exactly how but
we might see a situation where if white
continues waiting the black knight goes
to this square and then the other black
knight goes to this square it looks so
weird
remember as well that this black knight
actually started on the other side of
the wood um but black is just getting
ready everything later for this pawn
push
as simon said often this pawn push is
actually bad even if you can arrange it
but you just want to scare white with
the threat of this pawn push actually
often the just the idea of it is much
much uh kind of scarier than the reality
and uh in the current position yeah
especially all of these white pawns they
just lock down the position and prague
has full control but
unless if you uh ignore the evaluation
bar for a while it's still difficult for
white to find a plan apart from
containing black you need an active plan
yourself and often white would maybe
re-root the night start throwing pawns
forward towards the black king
just from my experience at least of
these positions but very tense very very
tense very locked up this position
and well
wei yi has a specific goal in mind that
is to win this game nothing else will
suffice and for our quiz of the day
we're asking what is your goal in chess
and the prize is a lifetime repertoire
of the taiman of sicilian
and fatima
says that
her goal is to become the first woman to
play in the candidates and maybe one day
even challenge the world champion
i love that fatima you go for it yeah go
for the top absolutely but have um
played in the candidates before she
played in a candidate's tournament yeah
and she played for the world
championship title when the world
championship was decided in a tournament
back was it 2007. she was certainly
strong enough to
compete and you know for the world
championship title at best so 2005 2007
around that time she was playing in
tournaments for the world championship
um so she's been close but yeah i mean
to take that final step to become world
champion overall that would be a
milestone in chess we're all cheering
for fatima yeah definitely
and
ryan baker i like this it's a very
simple
goal but it's a good one says uh that
their goal in chess is to simply never
stop feeling the thrill i do when i sit
down on the board
yeah and
and uh wow
what do you think would have to go back
to the game because uh white's king has
gone to the left you're not happy simon
i don't see why you have to commit your
king so much because as soon as you
commit your king in such positions you
just give your opponent a target and
he's got i mean maybe you know this the
the break on the other side of the board
is now key uh black should not be trying
to play the one near his king because
but he should be
able to play uh the b pawn up two
squares and
you know even if you sack a pawn in some
position you just need to open up lines
over there so i i i don't think prague
needed to put his king
so quickly and in that position he could
have he could have been a bit more
patient there
and now look the queen is coming yeah it
just seems a bit strange to give give
way year target over there why give your
opponent a target so this is the target
the white king and he's going back where
he came from with the white rook and i
think maybe prague not so familiar with
the ideas here but if we just backtrack
to the moment that key moment when he
castled his king i know a lot of top
players here who would have actually
spent two moves getting there he could
have had the same position uh he would
move his king one square forward no
matter what black does he moves his king
across and if you imagine for example
the black queen coming out this is the
position we have on the board but here
it's white to move
so basically we've got the position on
the board now with black to move wei yi
by doing what prague did by castling
queen side and only then pushing his
king up the board only then um sorry in
only then in this position bringing his
rook back where it started the game he's
lost one move
um so it's a small kind of trick of the
trade um which comes with experience
which comes from studying these types of
positions but he could have had the
exact same position just with his king
already on the square with himself to
move actually talking about that then is
is
that what uh for example his coach uh
ramesh is sort of looking at so after
this game and after this tournament
maybe that is something they will look
at and and work on definitely i mean
they'll they'll go deep on every single
move every single decision um i know
ramesh he's really one of the best chess
coaches in the world he's really
detail-oriented and he will pick apart
even price wins he'll say here you could
have won even smoother here you could
have kept more control um here you could
have had the same thing just with one
extra move like in this situation i mean
i'm not even saying it's a good plan
putting white's king on this side of the
board i'm inclined to agree with simon i
think it's very risky to put white's
king on this side but
if you could have done the same thing
with one extra move then it's i mean
it's definitely a better version so
uh meanwhile wii's
rook coming across black is definitely
trying to prepare that scary pawn push
at some point and we will reach boiling
point when it's just maximum tension wow
already 16. yeah and all 32 pieces still
on the board and they will likely remain
on the board for a while yet
okay now the black queen going back just
uh preparing this black pawn push
craig he must have fantastic fighting
chess index yeah yeah i think both these
players yeah
putting his king on that side is that a
fighting kind of move
yes okay
gutsy yeah
unnecessarily brave maybe when you only
need a draw kings on opposite flanks
always result in some kind of attack
simon oh sorry sorry i was just going to
say you know how realistic is it that
way yeah actually manages to
orchestrate that breakthrough on the
left
because
pragnanda does have full control for the
time being yeah i mean it's i suppose
it's in the long run i mean maybe you
can try to put the bishop where the
queen was
a minute ago and just you can get your
night get everything around there but
it's still very hard to do still
incredibly hard so i don't think
prague's decision is is that bad because
the position's so blocked you can pretty
much do anything you put your king
anywhere and you still got to break out
interesting question as well just on
chess 24 chat occasionally look at this
is by our friend chess in numbers and
we're just talking about prague and
who has the most potential in the future
to become world champion
and um it's really hard to say there's a
lot of pressure on them but we we've
mentioned ali raza farouja
and prague and it's very hard to compare
them of course obvious reasons but chess
chess numbers and i think it's our
friend uh thinks that prague um does
have the most potential if we're looking
at say four to five years from now so
that's quite interesting just by the
stats he's a stat guy just saying that
he he thinks prague is is you know
really really great chance obviously he
does we can see how much he's improving
or becoming a world champion but
compared to other players i i don't know
it's
it's it's it's interesting to see isn't
it and and uh to debate really who is
going to be the world champion of four
to five years it's interesting though
okay meanwhile we have had a really
dramatic pawn push on the board but if
we just see their stats there wei yi and
prague and on the tour ratings prague is
actually ahead uh by
almost 20 points but wei yi when he was
15 years old he was higher rated than
prague is now at 16. so just having that
potential having the rating having
achieved all those goals doesn't
necessarily mean you take the next step
wei yi is still fantastically strong
that's why he's in the quarterfinals now
but he's never made it into the world
top 10. he never broke through to
challenge the world top players on a
consistent basis despite breaking the
2700 barrier at only 15. so so it is
maybe about those years pregnant is
entering now yeah
i mean it's all about staying with that
love of chess taking chances playing as
much as you can
being brave against the world's best
players whe maybe hasn't had the
opportunities because in china the
situation's been different kovid
obviously
lots of factors but
you just have to keep improving don't
you that that's the simple thing and so
many players they just plateau and
there's not really any reason why they
plateau sometimes they just can't get
past a certain point so you've just got
to keep improving at this level and it's
very hard to do that when you get
stronger and stronger it gets harder and
harder to improve see
sorry i was going to say sometimes it's
like david says you know sometimes it's
just unfortunate that you reach this
level but maybe there are other talents
as well you know so
you don't get the same attention on the
opportunities
and well
big stuff happening in the pragnanda
game dramatic movies yes
big moment because we have seen the
first trade of pawns
so all 32 pieces were on the board uh up
until move 18 but uh now after this pawn
push by white we have reached boiling
point as mentioned and now black can no
longer avoid any trades if black just
waits and continues maneuvering then
white will simply push the pawns forward
and this is a pawn storm white will
steamroller black on the side of the
board pushing everything forward and
this black king is not going to survive
when things open up
uh so in the end we had to simply trade
he had to swap off this set of pawns and
now the black knight goes back because
white is the one with breakthroughs we
talked about those pawn breaks this pawn
break for black is controlled for now
now white has i think five uh if you
include pawns and pieces five uh pieces
controlling this square so black can't
break out yet
instead it's white pawn break which is
about to happen that is the key so black
retreats the knight in anticipation of
that
and the question is does white step
forward now does white break open the
center is he ready or is the king a bit
too open uh for example we could see a
trade maybe black will occupy this
outpost with his bishop with his knight
it still looks great to me for white i
must admit or will we see prague maybe
continue to build up or maybe even throw
some pawns down the board towards the
black king
so many options actually definitely i
mean my first thing to instinct was to
initiate the harry attack
but then i've kind of changed my mind i
think pushing in the center
just is just such a harmonious move
suddenly the knight has a nice square on
the on the e4
and uh i don't
why he probably has to capture that pawn
i can't you can't let such a fantastic
pawn stay on e5 but then the bishop gets
that beautiful
long diagonal attacking the rook
this looks fantastic and of course you
have your long-term trump the protective
pass pawn in the middle yeah might will
win any end games with this uh this pawn
yeah i mean it might fantastic it does i
mean i suppose after the exchange you
know you give away a square maybe the d6
square that black can put a piece on
and i mean it could even be
quite a clever um
clever time to have a look and think
what's black's next move because if
black moves that night again which has
just moved towards the queen side which
is not a ridiculous move trying to
support the pawn push then your idea
becomes even stronger and i'm just
thinking what other move can black play
if black moves the bishop
then i think you know to to try get on
the diagonal then maybe your pawn push
becomes even stronger um what's black's
next move i can't see what black's next
move is so maybe we can do your idea but
just prepare it like you know just ask
him black what are you going to do next
in a better in a better position here i
still think it's very strong i mean i'd
be tempted to play straight away as well
but just just it's always worth asking
what your opponent's going to do next as
well i feel like yeah because if they
don't have a move you can prove you just
improve yeah and just yeah
that's it
don't ever move improve beatbox do you
want the beatbox
no
i got some criticism from my from my
husband last night when he said you know
you know
you should have done a wrap okay well
let's try it
let's try now let's try problem the
problem is i i don't know how to rap
yeah the only wrap that i can do is the
raptor wannabe and that's just not great
oh oh that's a great one which one yo i
tell you what i want what i really
really want so tell me what you want
what i really really want i wanna
i don't even know when i was sick or
sick
that's a wrap that's good guys here's a
story from a to z if you want to get
with me better listen carefully you got
m in your face
easy free she doesn't come for free and
as for me you'll see
it's very nice it's not quite eminem but
you're nice
well anyway we do have action on the
board i can't believe i just did that
okay the pawn has moved forward to the
center next time fresh prince of bella
yeah
the breakthrough has happened so prague
deciding that this was the one moment to
pull the trigger and break open the
center well i don't know i think he
should have prepared it more but uh i
was gonna just wondering what spy scale
you'd be
yeah i just want as for me you'll see
what spice can we be what would it be
jerry sporty you'll be jerry
ginger ginger i know ginger ginger spice
okay the coolest actually yeah i thought
simon would be ginger spice though i
could try i could try here
who would we all be ginger spice i yeah
i don't know
you already said it haven't you
yeah yeah but it's clearly you though
simon yeah i'd have to be me wouldn't it
um so
i don't know
sport who's sporty
sporty love to be supporting spice i
know how to do her kick i've been
practicing okay that's next on the list
of things to see
tomorrow yeah prepares that uh sporty
kick uh we're seeing bishops come off
the board knights coming off the board
but is prague rushing
he's trading off the pieces and that
goes against conventional wisdom your
opponent's really cramped black had no
space black had no
squares for pieces simon mentioned black
had no moves almost and now he's trading
pieces liberating black's uh
black's army
don't trade pieces when you have extra
space that's the uh
that's how the saying goes and right now
let's jump in we did see uh we actually
predicted up to this point black
occupying the square with this bishop
and i thought here okay maybe just bring
your rooks to the center this rook this
rook just improve your pieces no instead
he trades improving this black knight in
the process and now he jumps forward i
think he's too hasty here prague i'm a
bit worried about the trend of this game
now the black knight goes back he should
not
kind of rush and continue trading
exchanging things off because black
actually gets a really nice night on an
outpost here knights are great
blockaders and this knight has influence
on both sides of the board black is
actually almost ready let's grab the
pawn yeah he's got greedy though he's
grabbed a pawn and
is this gonna backfire because actually
suddenly after this rook move
look at the white king look where it
stands it's on the same line as this
black rook lots of targets
and uh maybe it's good objectively for
white but you're losing a lot of control
taking massive risks if this white
knight returns then at some point there
will be this pawn break to watch out for
trying to crack open the line towards
the black
towards the white king and i just got
distracted there because we've seen
another couple of moves instead of going
back
he traded off and uh
he's lost a lot of
quality in his position white is one
point up now
and he's playing positionally but it's
all about the white king
maybe he's just got things under control
yeah
how i feel remember that's true but
somehow i feel that way ye will be in
his element here you know he thrives in
these tactical positions and
there is there are chances for white to
go wrong
but it does look like having said all
that that pragnanda is well his position
looks quite solid yeah he's one point up
and he's defending everything for now
but those black knights are going to
come i mean the thing is with these
positions the computer obviously says
that prague's better it has done from
move three but um just look at the white
king the white king's over there you you
can that that knight maneuver you just
mentioned david that's coming around to
the the queen side and there might be a
b pawn break just feels a little bit
like black has some chances at least so
the dark squares white is really
vulnerable so if the black knights can
jump around on dark squares to go for
that white king
potential chances it's
i mean it's in practical terms at least
much easier to play for wei yi than
prague especially compared to five moves
ago i still think prague is doing great
in a long game in a classical game if he
had one hour two hours he would win but
wow okay he's going for the attack
um yeah he's not scared at all it's not
safety first is it it's just not safety
first at all
i don't know i don't like this and the
reason i don't like it is because the
rook can go and attack the queen and
suddenly there's another avenue did you
see way ye as well he was a bit slouched
in his chest suddenly he got up and
they've got up and uh you can maybe even
move the queen two squares fours and
threaten some immediate ideas of uh just
blasting the position
oh
hello this is the first move on my radar
as soon as the evaluation bar shot um
and black is using this pin uh let's
jump in and uh explain because it's all
about this file that's where the white
king is that's where black's major
pieces are so break open that file at
any costs this knight jump
what a move um trying to jump in and
give a nasty check if white continues
pushing for example this is a royal fork
and uh white's queen drops off so you
have to remove this knight from the
board stop it getting in if you take it
with your pawn the black queen breaks
through
this is going to end in disaster if you
take with the knight then now okay again
your king lacks its best defender
and it's all about this file the black
knight about to jump and take this pawn
as well i think we're going to playoffs
oh wow you think we will actually win
this yeah i mean i i think pragnanda's
lost control
i think
i mean the only thing that i would be
doing here is if i were white i would be
desperately trying to swap off queens is
this possible can i bring your queen to
the edge of this yeah to the edge of the
boat but i mean quite a challenge but uh
of course way ye will say no having none
of that and stepped forward two squares
and then
what what is the white dude
i know it's very scary stuff this is the
dream attacking combo the queen and
knight and they're coming towards the
white king
yeah simon i mean i think you might be
right it's just the momentum we we
mentioned that yes white is still in
maximum control white was still doing
well but
things have been slipping
in black's favor slowly and i think this
last me is this star move
i'm not sure i would have found it but
as soon as the evaluation bar went that
way it's like okay there's something and
it's all to do with the white king
time is also not great another little
factor playing against prague but it's
just his position is really loosening up
now and it's now getting to a very
critical stage i mean he's still okay so
he could certainly hold this one but
he's got to uh he's got to find some
very accurate moves and it's very hard
to defend you know such positions i mean
computers can do it but humans finding
good defensive moves when your king is
getting more and more exposed
very tough i mean was this a brilliant
opening choice um from wei yi who who
knows that this opening is the check but
only oh it's it's a bit dodgy
but was it just it's worked out very
well at the moment i think to give him
chances with the black pieces yeah let's
see prague okay he's shaking he's trying
to get the energy pumping
but getting energy pumping when you're
on the defensive suddenly
i'm not sure it works that well and uh
okay he does decide to trade the knights
but
oh no this uh is not gonna end well
surely things opening up towards the
white king white has lost the best
defender the knight the knight is the
king's best friend and also pawns are
hanging on both sides of the board now
the white a pawn at some point might be
nice and juicy temporarily the black
knight is under threat you can just move
it though you could just retreat it to
go forwards if you want to
there could be something more violent i
mean i might
flick in an exchange of pawns here
because i want to open up the white king
as much as i can i mean that opens up
another line so why not flick it in but
this is the move that at some point is
just very worrying that night coming to
the central square is hitting everything
i mean it's such a strong night that one
yeah and
how wild is it if white just goes i'm
going to ignore it and uh
carry on
yeah and he hasn't done this uh maybe
you're right if i maybe had to try that
but okay he's lining up against this
pawn but this is easily defended
i mean black wants to put his knight in
this in the center anyway and he not
only attacks the queen attacks
everything but he defends this key pawn
and oh prague is holding things
together here by a thread
i don't know if it's going to work
though as simon mentioned at your will
you can capture a pawn trade off a set
of pawns look how open this king is
though
i mean you don't want to move the night
yet you don't want to allow a trade of
queens but
surely there's something just my spidey
senses are tingling but if his uh king
is a little open and uh all he needs is
a draw why should he not trade with
queens then black shouldn't trade
queensland okay so black cannot move the
knight for example to take the white
bishop because then there will be a
trade of queens and white king is
actually great in the center if queens
disappear but uh yeah black should be
the one keeping queens on the board in
the current position uh if we go back to
it black needs to keep this piece
so yeah maybe there's a small pressure
small problem for black because this
knight can't move without allowing that
queen trade
how do you move the queen while keeping
an eye on your knight
nicely i'm looking at ideas of taking
the pawn once and trying to play the
other pawn to that square which i i
don't think really works but it's the
kind of thing you're naturally looking
at just really violently trying to uh
open open things up by any means
necessary towards the king yeah i mean i
don't think probably on pass on works
well there but it's kind of close
because you do open up more lines and
your night drops but it's it's you know
that that white king is just it's just a
little bit loose if prague holds this
i'll be very impressed but saying that
way he has to find the next step here in
the in in the initiative what about for
example moving your queen out of the way
just so your rook can stare down on this
line and i'm looking at lines for
example black's queen threatening to
take this pawn because the sea pawn is
pinned if white now attacks this knight
then suddenly the black knight at the
very least could jump out the way i know
this would result in a queen trade but
maybe you can go for something like this
i mean it just feels like there's
something around this white king i can't
see it yet way you can't see it see it
yet
it's getting close though it's getting
very close well we can't see anything
maybe it's just uh
improved rook across so he defends his
knight as ivanka says improve
when you don't know how to move improve
and uh now because the black knight is
defended the black queen is free
so now she can come up the board or
maybe the black rook can start taking
this pawn defended by the black queen
it's falling apart for prague he needs
to find a way to swap queens or keep
control three minutes on the clock and
these two have played some very long
games right now they have played chess
for four hours so they're going above
four hours now will sort of fatigue
become an issue as well i mean way is
sitting but both of them are actually
playing at night yeah i mean for wei yi
it's what four am now exactly 4 am and
uh prague it's almost that late i mean
when you're young maybe you can adjust
yeah
as the years tick by
it's not so easy but yeah i'm sure
they'll be full of adrenaline right now
at least
i mean if it goes to playoffs if it goes
to blitz armageddon then it's definitely
a test of stamina mm-hmm
and i would say way has been very calm
and and you know seemed to be in control
the whole day
that's a trademark of the chinese school
of trust yeah
maybe that's an advantage now with you
know clock sticking adrenaline running
yeah and he's playing quickly as well
clearly where he's not tired if he's
playing this fast in a complicated
battle seven minutes up on the clock i
wonder how they trained the chinese
players to remain mentally calm because
they do generally when you see them
playing uh all the top players they do
seem to remain very calm at the board
very collective whilst uh you know um
that's not the case for for other
countries uh particularly i mean uh they
i haven't really seen her nervous i
imagine they play a lot of uh blitz and
fast time controls but uh you know
dingleroon has always been famous in the
chess world for actually not for being
relatively expressionless you know he's
winning losing in time travel seconds
left it's the same
over the board but
online
i've
we've seen dingler and many many times
be super
you know emotional you know he's been
shaking his head you know he's been
quite maybe not at the level of like
magnus carlsen no no no no no no but you
know it's it's very nice is what i'm
trying to get it's very nice to see the
players
give a little bit more and so we can see
oh yeah
this is really affecting them and uh
well
dragonanda moves his rook again
yeah it's very loose now white's queen
is not defended
again it just feels like there's some
tactics in the position and uh where ye
trying to look for them
still trying to work out as well for
example what happens if black's rook
comes and takes a pawn again you'll move
simon do you flick in a capture a trait
of pawns in front of the white king
first
it's hard just hard to work out the
differences right yeah it feels like
there's a step in the right direction
right to capture pawns the opening up a
bit more yeah the one downside in this
current position maybe behind trading
points is that the white bishop can now
take back i'm just slightly scared that
at some point the white pawn will push
forward and the white bishop is on this
diagonal um just while this pin exists
black unable to take this bishop because
the black queen would fall
so just temporarily i'm hesitant but
what about this move rook takes pawn
just uh hoping that after rook takes
this is the only variation i've worked
out maybe there's a flaw to the plan but
after the white rook now goes and
captures the black knight it looks like
white is a whole piece up but suddenly
after one check where do you put your
king there's no safe square no matter
where you go
if you go back forward the black queen
will actually drop down to this square
and if this is a skewer once the white
king moves the queen will take the white
rook and
um yeah here black would actually oh
sorry maybe even take with his own rook
black here is a head of material and the
white king is not going to survive for
too much longer
yeah this looks
looks good very strong for black i in
fact i i saw this move but for some
bizarre reason i only i thought it
worked if the white king went on to the
c line to see three square
there's a bit of a blindness there but
okay that was the variation with the c3
square and okay the
uh black moves across trying to take
this pawn
okay interesting trying to utilize this
pin that the black queen has on the
white king now and
very logical as well centralizing all
the black pieces all protected
coordinated these three pieces now yeah
lots of open lines about to come
interesting stuff
pregnant amanda i would hate to be in
his shoes two minutes left on the clock
as well
yeah and it does seem like pragnanda's
actually struggling to come up with a
plan he's just in complete defensive
mode yeah just uh
what to do i don't know i push a pawn i
think harry probably i mean i would hang
on is there some tricks no it's black
not threatening white central
i mean can he not just take the pawn now
i mean
what's the idea behind this last move i
mean uh black's last move seemed to set
up a fret uh you've got to look at your
opponent's last move always see where
it's pointing and that can't that rook
just take the pawn now
okay we have to jump in you guys are
mentioning a lot of moves there so um if
the black rook takes this pawn utilizing
this pin
then ivanka you think maybe bishop takes
pawns jumping out the way i've worked it
out but maybe this black rook
there i'm not 100 sure i don't see it
after the black's rook just captures the
white rook this bishop surely is going
to just drop off the board on the next
turn yes it will um you can give up your
bishop for a pawn but i don't really see
the idea behind it i don't see the idea
behind price move
rook takes pawn winning a pawn i'm not
sure white could have done much though
in in the last position it was actually
already looking like it was creaking
somewhat he plays it um and he's got his
pawn back now so he's not even a pawn
down seems like he's got the attack the
safer king this is this is going all all
his way i think at the moment
prague needs to play to for survival now
the white king is on the brink i just
checked and it says that uh you have to
make the move that pragananda has just
played
only move to survive trying to get some
counterplay of some sort so prague is
trying to distract wei yi he wants to
push his pawn one square further forward
actually cage the black king for example
if black is a bit slow retreating then
white's queen now wants to snake in and
trap this black king at least now some
counter
some counter play forces wayy to
think defensively the first time in this
game really and okay this is the current
position
there must be a breakthrough here trade
a set of pawns potentially or
i don't know double up your rooks
there must be something here for way it
looks beautiful for black this white
king just no man's land yeah i mean
there's one one phrase sharp line if you
double rooks i mean that that looks like
the most natural to me threatening the
bishop on d3 and now i'm wondering can
you play h6 anyway i don't think you can
um but you know it's possible possible
uh with the idea of um just sneaking the
queen in with some checkmate ideas so uh
this is certainly something
which is worth you know worth
calculating now but be very careful if
you're gonna play with fire like this so
yeah very very careful and it all
depends on whether this uh this bishop
is just gonna fall or whether black is
in time it's a race suddenly white's
attack is actually quite quick
um so i like prague's last move a lot
yeah going on the counter
as you guys mentioned maybe this was
just necessary giving away a pawn in the
center it's not intuitive but going um
for some attack against the black king
can you also plan to go like pawn takes
pawn i don't know whether that has any
and it all depends here on whether the
white bishop can take back if the white
bishop can't take back if the pawn has
to recapture it then this black rook is
just coming in
looks like that's winning but maybe
bishop takes pawn
and he's okay we're going to find out
he's okay
yeah it's opening up
can black's rook come in behind anyway
um suddenly at least white has some
counter play against this square
yeah i don't like that decision from wei
yi
maybe he
maybe he just couldn't see anything
better he's getting low on the clock as
well suddenly white has counter play
against the black king
and interesting it is a must win
situation for a way to take it too tire
breaks these two have played some long
long battles and here they are fighting
it out again
and is way
throwing it away making some mistakes
i mean i think both players are just
getting nervous at this point they've
done so well ice cold to even get this
far but it's understandable if nerves do
creep in okay absolutely a trade of
rooks to start
and the computer hates that one and will
we see white just recapture this rook if
so which way does he take back with the
king does he take back with a rook
i mean
there's other stuff to work out here
maybe
which way okay he takes back with the
king allowing the queen to give him a
check
suddenly it's level material white's
king though the question is is it a
target maybe it's just safe all the
pieces are coming off the board
kenya you go for the earlier plan that
you mentioned where the queen kind of
gives a check on the d6 square and then
snakes into the a3 square you know
keeping oh no but there's a bishop sorry
okay yep just to show your idea ivanka
if the queen does give a check the white
king moving the white the black queen
coming in this is this is very relevant
though because here it does look scary
the black queen coming to give some
checks but uh we mentioned white's
bishop improving enough to cause some
chaos of its own destruction bishop
takes pawn is a check and if the knight
recaptures then the black rook will fall
yeah prank's surviving well i mean i was
very very well i was very pessimistic
about his position as in it looked
horrible his king's so weak but he's
finding he's finding great moves to uh
well he can go wrong in so many
different ways he's finding very very
good moves to to not allow any tricks to
occur to his position it seems he's
doing it with pins if you look at this
diagonal that's one pin if you look on
the central file that's another pin if
you look at the black knight that's
another pin
so it's literally three pins here and uh
somehow he's just
yeah he's been walking a tightrope
prague but he's done it really well he
hasn't fallen off that top uh fallen off
that tightrope yet i've been actually
working on pins on chessable they have
some nice
move repetition practices with pence
recommended yeah
yeah
and uh yeah prague's definitely been
working on those
pins uh especially in this game i'm wei
yi look at the clock times as well he
had what was it seven eight minute
advantage just a few moves ago
that's disappeared
were you looking concerned i think he
might have
might have let this one slip yeah i mean
there still must be some chances surely
with with pieces so many pieces on the
ball but
white's starting to get his own threats
as well so it's you know you have to do
something soon and yeah i guess you have
to maybe kind of consolidate a little
bit because everything is working
because of the pins and i was thinking
this move i thought maybe it might be a
good idea to flick in the check first
and uh okay pragananda's threat of
bishop takes pawn
has been covered in some lines that
there's bishop takes place yeah i mean
you could go h6 here maybe threaten it
again in a very strange way uh if you
know if i flick the pawn to trap in the
black king maybe we can show that i i
start i start arranging some very strong
threats i mean the first one is just
bringing the queen in front of the black
king to check mate but i think bishop
takes pawn check uh is is also now
again a threat because i've trapped the
black king in so that that to me just
well i love using the h pawn don't i but
that to me looks just a very useful move
to play in the position yeah i think if
he has the time if he feels he has the
luxury um then definitely trap in this
black king and remember that's the trend
nowadays you push harry the h pawn
as we've just seen from prague in order
to create potential mating nets you
don't necessarily want to open up lines
you just push your pawn here firstly for
end games this pawn is only two squares
away from promotion but also this black
king now there's going to constantly be
threats against it and it might look
contradictory here but black's king is
maybe even worse than white's king
white's king at least it has a lot of
air to breathe it's a target for sure
but it can wander around it can run away
black's king
definitely in a cage at the moment
prague doing great yeah i mean really
really impressive so far uh i mean
now now where ye is under a little bit
of pressure he's got two frets he must
stop i think you can check with the
queen for example to stop both those
frets but
then what you do next because the white
king will improve his position and then
the new threat will be on the board and
that's just uh sliding the rook across
to attack the question right yeah and uh
backrank mate is a problem
as well as maybe bishop takes pawn still
actually so there's yeah that but moving
the rook is very strong isn't it so it's
actually you know maybe maybe trickier
for black all of a sudden
um yeah i mean if both sides drop under
one minute it's just completely random
it's a lottery i think we'll see a
checkmate or a checkmating idea on the
board against one of the kings just not
sure which one great move from prague
locking in the black king and that
background checkmate we talked about
earlier today um putting pushing a pawn
forward creating some lift um is one way
to deal with it but prague has basically
made that idea irrelevant taking away
this key square
so yeah it's
uh wow literally both sides on 50
something seconds now
oh one way he obviously knows he has to
win this game desperately looking for a
way to do just that but the clock is
ticking oh
there's i just spotted another trick but
uh
wait wait you should not move the knight
no certainly
that would be a bit painful that would
say uh the black knight moves then the
white queen just captures the black
queen and checkmate coming yeah yeah
there's also queen takes pawn
oh even nicer
okay i'll go knight d7 just uh just to
show your idea
yeah for example if the black knight
dares to move and capture this bishop um
then queen takes queen is winning uh
with a nasty checkmate background
checkmate but uh ivanka mentioned
something even more brutal if the black
knight for example five seconds
somewhere else then queen takes born
we'll end in checkmate will we see this
on the board he's got how many seconds
did he have left there actually captured
the pawn wow he had two seconds left
unbelievable and he's taken this pawn
now the big question is what is
happening
i mean i was going to say a move that
might be a mistake here but i don't know
if the queen comes in trying to check
mate
it's so complicated
okay so
first of all we have to work out the
checks you have to be methodical but you
can okay he hasn't played it he's played
simon's idea bishop takes pawn check
this looks very logical as well just
trying to exchange off and now he's
trying to trade but it's the white king
open here it feels so open it does yeah
both kings are exposed but blacks to
move first black moves first he can
flick the checks in first but maybe the
white king can hide for example if the
black rook gives a check
the white king moves towards safety on
the side of the board
okay it's moved to this corner now the
black queen where does it give check the
white king maybe it's gonna hide
i mean it's a miracle if prague holds
this one two seconds okay so he's
checked on the a3 square but now you can
block with a queen if you if you uh
you know just try to keep everything
safe i mean that looks all right
yeah play it safe bring back the white
queen yeah i mean if you if you could
move the king you
yeah okay he's gone for it
i'm sorry so impressed with absolute
lack of fear it's incredible isn't it i
mean prague playing this way is
remarkable i think the key is that the
black rook cannot go across and check
the white king now because the white
queen covers any square the black rook
wants to check from so black's queen is
the only one which can give check
you have to keep giving check because if
you give the move to white white is
going to checkmate the black king and
here we go there's no way to continue
the attack we might have a drawback
perpetual check here right moves i think
this is going to head to try out
personally i i think this is one of the
most impressive prague games i've seen
um not necessarily from the way he
played the opening or the early middle
game but when his position started to
look difficult the way he played
so accurately lots of people would
crumble but he's he's played this uh
so well from a tricky position i'm going
to see a result any moment now wei yi
looks resigned to the fact that this
game is going to be a draw and prague is
going through to the semi-finals black
has nothing else to do you have to give
checks to avoid checkmate and there we
go third time we've seen this position
it's over a
marathon match between these two ends up
with pragnanda the 16 year old making it
through to the semi-finals he finally
stops